a state of emergency was declared in
Australia overnight as firefighters
continue battling massive out-of-control
brush fires at least 17 people have died
as a result of the fires Australia's
military is helping communities
devastated by the flames
Natasha Axl B of our news partner
Network 10 news in mallacoota where
evacuations are underway that's where we
find our the this morning good morning
Natasha good morning Tony the country is
well more than a quarter of the country
is on fire this state of emergency is
rocking Australia to its core we've got
main roads closed and they could remain
that way for weeks so people are trapped
which is why the military has been sent
in to commence mass evacuations from
7:00 a.m. tomorrow morning
local time and people will be taken to a
port near Melbourne and it will take
about 17 hours to get there
priority is going to be given to the
sick the elderly and families also with
young children hundreds have homes have
been destroyed more than 100 in this
area alone and this disaster that I'm in
right now it unfolded on New Year's Eve
when locals and tourists they fled to a
beach as those bush fires rolled through
the sky turning it bright red
firefighters are working around the
clock most of them are volunteers by the
way they're not being paid and the most
concerning part of all is that we're
expecting temperatures to rise in the
next 24 to 48 hours so our biggest
battle may actually be ahead of us
Jericka while some unbelievable pictures
there Thank You Natasha
you